okay if you switch changes of the day
what is the first thing you do I'm Scott
these are the shopping questions and I'm
Freddie Flintoff and these are my
shocking answers Scott is my question
bodyguard when I want to skip a question
I'll press the buzzer he'll get a shock
you got to go are you like a you like a
better younger me aren't you Myra we're
celebrity would you most want to go on
date with Amadeus date with remind for
14 years do you know what you know you
aren't gonna do it with Owen car that's
what I'll be the person he's amazing
what is your sexiest feature what's your
most embarrassing interaction with celeb
I had a shoe embarrassing moments
resides I was on a night out in London
after film in a league of the wrong and
was in a nightclub called whiskey missed
shocking place but I was chatting to
this lad for ages and I thought it was
Theo Walcott use Everton now so I can
ask no I was talking England chances and
then was in the car on the way home and
I was at James Corden I saw it James
ease although I do not feel Wolcott so
what I saw what I'm talking to more
night it was it it was a Marvin from JLS
nice silver if you switch changes of the
day what is the first thing you do I can
council this please you're not my hero
anymore
what was the most embarrassing thing
you've ever done ever there's been a few
TV programs probably the peddler was up
there in the West Indies yeah and
possibly turned down his Street bind
room I've been stumped stumbling out
having won the ashes in 2005 allegedly
being in the garden which wasn't me
I did get rumbled in the Cabinet Room
I went wandering around the house I was
looking for rooms that I recognized them
not been doors because he was like
through the keyhole and who caught ya
why was it I was in this room and I
recognized as a Cabinet Room yeah
so I sat at the table in the Prime
Minister's chair I started Austin meal
meeting and I got really comfortable
having tray on the server I had a bottle
of exome and um and then the security
guard or policeman you can so Thor said
what would you bet your fun now
oh yeah I got frog-marched now this
wasn't this wasn't a problem
who would you rather go on a camping
trip with Robbie Savage or patty
McGinnis cause this for me Robbie Savage
I'm only because pan is just over than
have you ever not made it to the
bathroom more time say that yes really a
couple of times one of them was
embarrassing I was waiting to bat Awards
Australian or one day international and
I was trying to lose some weight at the
time which is always a constant map ad
DS like good cause a Nicole yeah and
they split the fat off for me food and
it came out by the back end a bit of an
accident I didn't make that decision
have I got time so yeah change so I
quickly wash myself off in the sink in
the corner of the room I walked up this
way just as I saw it myself I watched
the wiki and I walked out to bat Lords
I was thinking that you're not expected
anyway I've just been to deliver this
round what's the last thing you searched
on you phone dogs actual problems who is
the worst dress member of the top gear
team say yourself yourself I'm designer
[Music]
what is the image on your phone that you
would least like to get public the image
on the phone yeah right so that now last
question would you rather have a finger
for penis or penis for a finger what a
finger for penis or penis for a finger
[Laughter]
hopefully flintov Scott was my biggest
fan
this is shocking anxious
you